yeah five-minute little ice is here we
forward to do against you for the dollar
question okay let's uh let's play some D
6 g6 set up and see what my opponent
comes up with with G 3m this is so quite
a good line some interesting to them to
play like this um if you want them what
to control the game and have a slightly
slower pace let's put it this way just
complete development and secure the
center so um I'm not not really sure
what what's the right antidote against
this don't play this opening regularly
that's black okay maybe I can take an
term go go for knight c6 hour later I
was thinking about 96 now but maybe he
can just take and play a five but it's
not a big deal right poopy five Bishop
c6 rupee aids should be okay yeah
probably i'm just playing the normal
muthiya theoretically but spending it
spending loads of time yeah normal looks
long no Bishop e3 or maybe still taking
I don't know take take five rook takes
d5 Bishop c6 rook be eight and then ok
this is also also am a typical maneuver
retreating the night to leave black with
all his his minor pieces
because some plugs got a little bit of a
space disadvantage what about b5 here v5
before maybe it is a good idea to
quickly get pressure on the poem I hope
it doesn't have a direct technical
refutation could could be it's not done
looks a bit shaky on the long diagonal
all night XP five a plane night XD for
this should be okay unless I'm losing
material and some weird way that I'm not
seeing at the moment the idea is to play
be five now am I not prepared if I would
prepare this move let's say root b8 you
might have g-form be 593 this idea and
then this e3 nut can go to e2 all right
so a three year so a 5mm is the the way
to get this before moving okay so he
wants to take I see but he wants to take
take take rookie head Queenie eight and
then 95 probably but I have ideas like
taking on d5 and Queen 87 check at the
night night to defy this must be okay
for black I don't think that this this
can be a big a big issue if I play Queen
a7 now is God Bishop e3 this is nonsense
and but but what about just 90 XD form I
can take it for 9 a-7 I can play Queen
897 I can play Queen 87 so why not just
take this yeah I can just take it 97
Queen a seven he didn't have the time at
the time to play King H more knocking
age to this typical
um securing moves that help against
those tricks yeah just one the central
porn is yet still will be somewhat
tricky because of the time i'm down a
minute and yeah this was the move that I
I was some thinking about that might be
coming it might become a bit tricky so
hmm if I go just Knight to f6 sake and
take it take g6 maybe I can take first
take and then Knight f6 he threatening
upon to f6 this is the problem yeah
maybe not sure this is the best move but
I need to catch up a bit on the clock
now Bishop g5 for some annoying now
I don't want to take on d5 reading okay
he wants to take and play 95 again so
maybe make sure that I have roped g8 at
some point and not Bishop to g5 and rope
g8 so group GH rock g8 Queen f7 I can
play 98 right oh no no no no then you
can take a plane 97
yeah okay come on still I still attorney
to get something going here on the
gphone hmm the time time warning Jack
Jack yeah I simply play too slowly very
stupid I mean this was just just winning
for black with good play and proper time
management yeah Queen f6 okay I don't
have any time left yeah okay that's yam
ok so I lost thread yet it but it's not
so easy I mean it's a poem and and all I
said that but it's it's still tricky
yeah this is not easy to play it on I
mean at the beginning of all this it was
just winning it's clear justjust in
central porn but it's not easy at all
yeah here for example yeah the computer
move here just just winds on the squat
94 but I didn't didn't consider this
94 is so probably relatively easy night
XD for Queen txt 5 end and like unties
oops didn't want to go back so many
moose just want to show this shot here
Knight f6 I mean this keeps an advantage
but this is probably just killing what
is why it's supposed to do probably take
here and then my queen comes right in
the middle of the board and I am managed
to get rid of this knight on d5 FC
Bishop f8 yeah this looks scary to a
human computer who computer not so much
now computer accesses this is winning
but it's not so not so easy i mean this
position looks still a bit scary for
humans with the bad King on g8 but that
if I certainly am so better than what I
played here it's it's some compensation
at T I'm already had already worse
probably so it's easier to play for
white you can just play those active
moves yeah thanks for watching